Hey Oh what you gonna do hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to the lost box now I played this game a
while ago and I did pretty good at it by
beating level 3 but the full game came
out a while back
and now there's up to level 10 so if you
didn't see me play before you can see it
and how good I was at the game and now
I'm gonna play it again
and try to get past level 3 which is the
[ __ ] um that's gonna do good now if you
don't remember with lust but it's all
about it's frickin insanity
it's totally bonkers and it's almost
impossible to wrap your head around it
it's probably not even pleasant to watch
you should all turn off the video right
about now because it's not gonna get any
better than this
okay so now the do it oh god there we go
oh God oh [ __ ] buckets my high score is
14001 I don't remember losing that I
remember being really terrible at it
over a nori and then losing my goddamn
mind while trying to be this stupid son
of a [ __ ] game bang well to at least a
little bit of my memory doesn't seem to
have left me I seem to be somewhat good
god [ __ ] me in the butt oh man titties
titty sprinkles
hey okay there we go alright
by the way prepare for a lot of cursing
because pretty much all this is ever
gonna be is this gonna be a whole lot of
yes I did it okay sorry to scream
directly into the mic it's not exactly
my intention that's all I can do at the
moment actually yeah
baby I do remember just what you mean
yes
oh god oh no no no no no aah aah it's
gonna suck I got to be so terrible so
bad
I mean I'm obviously not bad I'm
obviously better than a lot of people
have playing this game I don't mean like
that in a bragging since I'm talking
about most people not to nevermind I'm
I'm pretty much at the bottom of the
barrel in terms of skill
there's no redeem oh God this always
happens I start out good then I get
floppy and bad aah always ends up like
sloppy 17th for me and then finally I
get a winner over on the 19th attempt oh
it hurts
why'd you hurt me why do you emotionally
wound me I love you and yet you keep
throwing me into the dirt okay anyway
time to suck it up not anything in
particular I'm sucking but I'm just
saying Jen generically it's time to suck
it up there we go level three what are
you gonna do that that old trick I've
seen that a million times and done
better in fact
you suck dawn oh god damn it [ __ ] me ha
ha ha ha
man titties oh okay hot ah
it's horrible I can't hope for anything
but to survive
I can't even hope to survive oh oh not
these oh not these oh no no I remember
you
hey all right I did it I thought it was
gonna move
I already got to level four why is that
an achievement unlocks it's not like it
was just random chance before Shrek oh
hey yo what's gonna do nothing we're
gonna die that's what I'm gonna do
I lost my calm bro Oh God hey [ __ ] me oh
[ __ ] I made it oh god what what do i do
there you're a dick
you're a big floppy weenie who yeah sack
dynamo won yes oh so good oh oh oh so
scary
Oh why's it gotta be so I'm what I'm a
don't I just look at the waveform on
this audio file just Oh for the entire
video
what beating seasons I'm gonna lose my
damn mind
I remember I was losing my damn I mean I
had a goal is just to beat Lowell 3 and
I did that like in the first try
I guess my skills done I should shut up
alright I'm ready for you bring it on
bring it on you douche knuckle I'm gonna
show you who's boss I'm gonna spank your
rump call you mama not that I do that
normally understand in this specific
scenario that's what I'm gonna do cuz I
feel like it free country I don't judge
me I ain't gonna judge you
spanked whoever's rump I feel like it
even if it is my own lonely on a Sunday
evening I suck it's late
what's funny about this is that I have
to spend so much brain or resources to
concentrating on what I'm doing that my
voice box centers of my brain doesn't
work too good and they come up with a
name [ __ ]
like I'm gonna oh like I'm gonna spank
my rump and call me mama we know that's
what i'ma do what the [ __ ] am I talking
about I am literally going insane here
aren't I I have literally lost it I am I
am NOT a high functioning citizen of
society yeah [ __ ] oh I went the wrong
way
[ __ ] yeah I thought I died therefore see
whoa I don't even know what happened
yeah why does it I did it
what are you gonna do nothing go pull up
[ __ ] you that's what I shouldn't have
gone for it I'm on [ __ ]
I really got nothing else to say do you
want some clever comment sir you came to
the wrong video it's gonna be the most
abnormal [ __ ] you've ever heard of
your life Oh what you gonna do titties
titties titties [ __ ] ease shitty titty
[ __ ] what was they doing
Alex concentrating too much on whining
like a little [ __ ] and not focusing on
being a winner the weird that I find the
voice strangely arousing is not really
sexy voice maybe oh my god am I still
alive
holy tips yeah yeah oh finally back here
Jesus okay ah oh I figured you didn't
know I didn't I didn't figure out oh I
got a new high score hey I feel good
about myself
I haven't felt good about myself in a
long time oh I wonder what he'll be
happy again after this I wonder how this
is gonna affect my brain chemistry boy I
can only imagine if someone took acid
and did this game seasons I mean at a
certain point it just kind of loses out
of actual concentration and it just
turns into like muscle memory like you
have to oh [ __ ] oh I got you baby
what
okay irmita chairman shove it I should
have stopped when I got the new high
score I shut us up I got greedy I wanted
more
oh that's what I get for wanting more in
life should just give up give up on your
dreams oh he's gonna be a failure Gabbar
nobody shot me cuz we're people
officially determined that I am actually
insane I've actually lost my mind five
nights at freddys so long time ago oh
all right let's not do this let's do a
little bit of [ __ ] oh god what do you do
wait wait think you're cool [ __ ] you oh
I thought that was gonna I thought that
was gonna be the level transition there
ah oh I gotta be on my side for that one
I gotta be on my side for that one I
gotta be on my side for now and I got me
out like I'm for that one
[ __ ] it's been a good day like I
recently discovered that they put up
every single episode of whose line is it
anyway on whatever website that it is on
now that it is you can Google and I
don't even remember what every episode
is on there
I've just been chained watching every
one of them because I recently lost my
downloaded collection of them I pirated
but don't tell no one
definitely don't tell over a million
people that I did that cuz there was no
other watch it's just one of my own
Trail here don't please don't put me on
trial here oh god they're fast
oh I got you oh so good god damn this up
[ __ ] I'm done ah
titty sprinkles god dammit [ __ ] okay
alright so that's philosoph ox I
literally don't think I'm gonna get any
better at this game because god dammit
it gets my blood boiling and I'm just
terrible in everything and also it
reflects some weird inner demons in my
in the back of my subconscious so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to see more cool games and I've
stressed my way through check out the
links in the description thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
[ __ ] hey hey hey Oh hate every part
of it I hate everything in life